tasha kheiriddin à toronto chantal
hébert à montréal michel c'est aux jets
à montréal également bonsoir messieurs
n'aiment pas ça on va si vous le voulez
bien rapidement nom vaut quand même le
montrer le sondage quotidien de la noce
vous aimez tellement les sondages je
peux vous en privez ou c'est vous passé
quatre mois à 30,9 30 vers le cap et
30,1 lie à 30 30
ça ne pourquoi je tenais à en parler au
début comme ça c'est simplement pour
souligner que ça ne bouge pas depuis
maintenant je dirais 4 5 jours c'est ce
que vous constatez et pourquoi
chantal d'abord il ya eu plus qu'un
sondage aujourd'hui alors si ça peut
vous faire encore plus plaisir il y en a
un qui montre les conservateurs
légèrement en tête y en a un autre qui
montre que le npd probablement en tapant
voulez vous que je continue et la bonne
nouvelle pour nous journalistes c'est
que il ya un sondeur dans son analyse
qui disait cette élection est un
cauchemar pour les sondeurs mais au-delà
de ce qui se passe rien parce qu'ils
aient pas eu d'événements marquant deux
points tournants qui a fait que en n1
quand perdu des plumes à l'autre et je
peux pas vous dire de quoi ça aurait
l'air soit pointé est ce que est ce
qu'on peut dire tasha et michel que la
toute la première partie de la campagne
avec des semaines faut le dire le très
difficile pour les conservateurs que
cette première partie là elle est comme
aux oubliettes là on recommence une
nouvelle campagne où on ne peut pas dire
s'attache à mais je pense pas qu'il est
complètement aux oubliettes on a vu la
montée de l'alpe est d'ailleurs 40% là
certains sondages ensuite descendre on a
vu les questions de réfugiés survenir et
tout le monde a dit que ça ferait perdre
tous les clubs au parti conservateur ce
n'est pas arrivé
alors c'était peu à commander en anglais
sting grande on a vu ce qui peut se
passer maintenant pour la deuxième phase
de la campagne je pense c'est vraiment
ça va être les promesses à la loupe des
partis parce qu'ils seront forcés
effective
lundi il a déjà fait de montrer comment
inventer pour toutes ses promesses la
d'habitude on voit pas ça au tout début
d'une campagne sauvian mi-campagne
maintenant la campagne est deux fois
plus longue alors c'est je pense à votre
tube never tout scrutin sur cette cet
élément là et on va on va avec on va
vraiment examiner à la loupe les cats
financions d'en parler michel rapidement
pardon hier le npd a déposé un cadre
financier déjà y avait quelques
questions 3 il ya encore plein de
questions vous savez je voudrais juste
un exemple les transferts en santé des
transferts il ya 2 il ya deux types de
transferts ceux qui sont conditionnels
que ceux qui sont inconditionnel alors
par exemple des jo à québec les gens les
business à ça c'était monsieur fourni à
discuter il ya juste une personne qui va
répondre à des questions sur la santé
quand il y aura une période des
questions c'est moi c'est moi qui va
choisir comment on va dépenser l'argent
ça sera pas le gouvernement fédéral
alors déjà c'est commencer là alors pour
arriver à aux chiffres qu'il voulait sur
la santé et l augmentation qu'il voulait
des transferts en santé ont été obligés
de mettre leurs promesses sur
l'alzheimer sur le nombre de médecins
sur ces sources à et d'en faire des
transferts conditionnels ben là déjà ça
ne marche plus - m et patrice y avait
des points d'ancrage vraiment différent
entre les parties on serait pas en train
de regarder ces sondages là et moi très
franchement les lecteurs qui scrutent
chaque première une par une il cadre
financier j'y crois pas je trouve que
c'est quelque chose que nous on fait est
ce que les lecteurs généralement en
retire c'est le bol c'est à dire
l'aviation en général oui l'impression
par exemple que peut-être que le cadre
financier du npd a pas envoyé le message
tout va bien coquelles le npd aurait
voulu avoir demain mais mais mais sur le
fond j'ai l'impression moi que ça va se
jouer plus sur la tête du client est la
raison pour laquelle je pense c'est
parce que il y en a pas de grands thèmes
- on peut dire c'est blanc et noir j'ai
couvert l'élection du des brèches en jeu
on savait qu'ils étaient pour l'entente
de libre-échange qui étaient contre mais
là on n'est pas là dedans et on a des
points à l'école différence
différenciation entre les parties et
cordialement les conservateurs ne
n'augmenterait pas les impôts les télés
vidéo promet des déficits il ya
certaines choses qui sont assez claires
ou noir et blanc c'est pas des énormes
enjeux comme le libre échange c'est sûr
mais à l'aller les roannais dans la mort
et autant pour l'électeur moyen il ya
personne qui dit je vais vous enlever
toutes vos baisses d'impôts des dix
dernières années
on y va vraiment pas dans quelque chose
à ce que vous entendez des gens discuter
avec passion de haut il va faire un
déficit de 10 milliards lui on a un
surplus de 2 à part nous autres je veux
hier d'ailleurs ses frappes à jour une
parentèle on va aller aux images
je me suis donc fait une mise en scène à
chaque jour de débat dans une seconde à
canossa rappelle son père dont on va y
revenir mais ça m'a frappé hier le débat
aux états unis les candidats
républicains
comment la ja d un monde entre les
propositions démocrates et les
propositions républicaines et
effectivement ici on est tous pas mal
sur le sens entre un bordeaux en un
système politique qui nous qui oblige
les parties allaient vers le centre
alors que le système américain et
présidentielle fait en sorte que pour
est élu candidat de votre parti vous
devez aller aux extrêmes à droite si
vous êtes et red bull qui à gauche ou
des verts démocrate qu'après ça c'est la
course pour venir au centre pour nous il
reste au centre est il un parti qui
s'envole du centre d'habitude eu
beaucoup de difficultés d'un système
parlementaire
on va regarder ces images vous en
parlait on les a montrés manuel ne les a
montrés tout à l'heure alors est bon
dans la brume en plus si t'as qu'à
regret il fait du canot il se prépare
petite mise en scène avant chaque débat
sans gilet de sauvetage ou avec un viol
auxerre est fait aux canadiens qu'aux
temps de parler que de ça j'en aurais
parlé que de ça il a dû penser débat ce
soir on s'amuse là mais débat ce soir
sur l'économie sipa que diffuse le
youtube les réseaux sociaux bien pas les
réseaux sociaux sur le globe and mail
sur le site c'est important ce débat là
ça beaucoup beaucoup parce que c'est le
dernier débarque en anglais chantal oui
c'est important dans l'état actuel des
choses où on ne réussit pas à voir dans
l'électorat un mouvement dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
à partir de ce moment là tous les
événements forts il y en a pas beaucoup
on n'a pas de grand débat en anglais
collectif avec les grands réseaux ont
une certaine importance ce qui va en
sortir par contre j'ai hâte de voir
parce que disco économique dans le
moment là après avoir regardé le npd
hier c'est vraiment éditeurs comme comme
discours de la part des trois partis
c'est vraiment dire untel est pas bon et
moi je suis bon est-ce que la cote des
coûts devrait être intéressante jusqu'à
la fin c'est bien de voir d'achat oui je
disais il ya deux trois jours je crois
c'est comme si c'est un pull statu quo
ou presque dans les trois cas les gars d
y aller les vous avez raison vous avez
du talent oui plus de déficit et oui un
peu plus de taxes mais c'est comme si
depuis neuf ans ce rappeur avait
remodelé la façon dont l'état fédéral
fonctionne et que personne remet ça
fondamentalement en question d'agen mais
je parle s'écoute nage pas je pas
d'accord exactement je pense que les
aider
et les libéraux ont essentiellement
changer de place le npd de retrouver
c'est de retrouver le centre et être
telle le prudent la personne prudente
sur le plan fiscal les libéraux
retrouvent le monde est difficile tout
le monde dit qu'on peut pas faire des
déficits et libéraux diaw y on va on va
laisser ça de côté et c'est contre la
logique qui dit que tous les partis
maintenant adopter une ligne plus
conservatrices sur la gestion de
l'argent alors je pense que oui il
essaye de refaire ce cadre mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya pas beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre il ya un petit surplus ce
n'est pas énormément alors des grands
projets les vraiment grand projet c'est
impossible de financer mais une vision
économique il faudrait qu'on voit dans
ce débat là monsieur un peu très
clairement la base et la prospérité
canadienne telle qu'il la voyait sur les
ressources naturelles
le dollar canadien est lié directement
au cours du pétrole c'est un
pétrodollars c'est devenu sa les deux
autres partis disent barça c'était une
arabe
moi j'aimerais que je suis un peu
défendre sa vision que les deux autres
partis nous dise où il voit l'économie
canadienne a les oreilles parce qu'à un
moment donné la des jeux un comptable
sur le budget de l'art
je pense que c'est la chose la plus
intéressante pour les électeurs d'abord
sur le taux de talhouët chanteur au
sujet au sujet du pétrodollar
qui gonfle et donc par les richesses
naturelles le premier premier ministre
que moi j'ai couvert qui est allé faire
un discours pour dire qu'on allait
devenir ce genre d'état donne une
superpuissance énergétique 7 les paul
martin à peu près n'importe quel
gouvernement aurait surfer sur la vague
des richesses naturelles au cours des
dernières années s'il l'avait eue et qui
avait pu surfer dessus alors quand on
dit ce qui venant à peu à tout miser la
tulle c'est court un peu et même des
musées nature et un autre à sa place je
leur ai fait aussi essayer les
entreprises privées aussi qu'ils ont
fuies qui ont investi c'est pas lui qui
a dirigé les investisseurs avertis
d'augmenter mais c'est vrai que je me
souviens de paul martin à londres qui
avait invité lors d'une de ses tournées
il y en a pas eu tant que ça n'a pas été
si longtemps poids mais je me suis
précisément à landes où il avait fait
l'apologie du canada comme terre
d'investissement pour les pour le
pétrole pour le gaz naturel venait
effectivement une manne qui pensaient
michel mais la question se pose
qu'est ce que notre vision économique
global qui s'opposent à sa où il ya
peut-être un manque d'imagination je ne
le sais pas on verra peut-être ce soir
mais les débats sur le taux taxe là on
peut pas faire 22 minutes avec ça 15 17%
patrice je regardais aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs organes de presse ont publié
dix idées neuves pour l'économie et cinq
idées neuves pour l'économie et je me
disais c'est pas les idées qui manquent
ça a été le courage d'en choisir pour en
faire un programme électoral et la tue
on peut pas dire que les partis
d'opposition sont distingués milanello
par le courage de dire moi j'ai des
idées qui sont différentes et les voici
mais les idées elles existent on les
voit le juste analyse sur l'internet
aujourd'hui on va en avoir plein bon
alors je rappelle c'est ce soir ce débat
sur l'économie
on va regarder ça avec beaucoup
d'intérêt va s'en reparler demain est ce
qu'il y avait d'autres il y avait un
petit extrait oui on voulait donner
denis lebel on écoute je reviens en une
petite conclusion n'écoute denis lebel
et lorsque je vous dis c'est que quatre
les gens sont en vacances
quant à la pêche qui sont sur le terrain
de golf ou sur leur veine où il n'écoute
pas beaucoup ce qui se dit depuis le
retour de la fête du travail
de plus pour la fête du travail je vous
avais plus les et peut-être que les gens
l'ont mené lu ou entendu aujourd'hui on
pense la campagne tout le monde oeuvre
autour de la fête du travail
ça va être vraiment le début de la vraie
campagne bon aujourd'hui on veut répéter
le message je suis le bel qui répétait
une annonce qui avait été fait
une attaque a fait contre le npd pizza
savait pas et on lui fléchi mais sur 10
ouais mais c'est vous qui allez décider
de déclencher le premier ou d'achat oui
mais c'est ça j'allais dire là ce qui
dit que c'était tout un gaspillage de
timbres les intelligente sa part qu on
travaille ça non mais en plus le plus la
fête du travail les sondages et me
semble bon de mal en pis au québec pour
les conservateurs pourraient croire
qu'ils avaient près de faire les
élections pendant que les gens étaient
en vélo à la plage on perd nos ballons
michel mais je vous dirais bien déjà sur
le sourire et dans lequel je suis le
belge parce que je me suis vu un sourire
ou effectivement très bien messieurs
dames toujours un plaisir